hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
[Applause]
get after me it's monday this could be
the next shut up bill
all right it's monday october 19 2020.
what are you gonna do with this week
that the lord gaveth you
what you gonna do what you gonna do with
this [ __ ] week
i'll tell you what i'm gonna do i'ma
i'ma i'm not gonna watch the news
i'm not gonna be on social media he puts
you in the best [ __ ] mood
you know what i mean you know what
social media is it's like that [ __ ]
it's like having a [ __ ] neighbor
and every time you're feeling good about
yourself you like what you're doing
all you got to do is go on social media
and you'll feel [ __ ] horrible about
yourself so
um yeah but if you don't pay attention
the news
man and you don't know what's going on
man
you don't bring up politics with anybody
like i did the other day oh
jesus is an hour and a half of my life
neither one of us will ever get back
and we're still voting for the same
person we're going to vote for in the
beginning it was stupid
i think i said six times during the
conversation going like this is dumb i'm
not going to convince you you're not
going to convince
me and that was the only thing we agreed
on and then we continued
to hammer each other with our air quote
points
um anyway i got a i got a huge
announcement to make
uh one of my great friends in this
business
dean del rey has a podcast let there be
talk guess who his guest is this week
huh none other than ac dc
brian johnson and angus young are going
on dean del rey's
podcast because they saw
his i guess they saw when he was doing
his tribute to bon scott
in the unbelievable show sorry my
phone's on and the unbelievable show
that dean put together and how hard all
those musicians
you know went that night that they were
like who the hell is this guy
this is a let's go on his podcast it's
the coolest thing ever
dean is absolutely over the moon
that he got there brian johnson and
angus young
are going dean del let there be talk
episode that comes out
today go listen to that
all right okay now for those of you
who aren't into ac dc and are still
listening to this podcast how are
how's it going how are you how's it
going i watched a little bit of football
today
and then uh i had to do some dad stuff
which is always fun so i watched the
patriots
first denver uh drew champ came back
led his team uh philip lindsay
[ __ ] killed us the running back and
uh i think our offensive line
the pats we got some injuries so they
moved some guys around and uh
cam didn't have a lot of time to throw
yadda yadda yadda we were still in it
towards the end
um but i was still trying to figure out
stuff
up there in new england but they still
you know
they're still fun to watch and all that
it's just it's a whole new
system for cam a whole new quarterback
so i am
beyond patient with this team and i'm
not going to [ __ ] about him because i
love the pats
from way back sullivan stadium
you know tony east and steve grogan
those days so
um uh die hard with these guys so it's
gonna be fun to watch them put this
thing together we certainly
have an absolute beast as a quarterback
and uh i think our defense is playing
great it's just we're not quite clicking
on the offense so the defense spends a
little much too much time out there
and you know how that goes but still the
defense did not let them in the end zone
i tweeted i was like death by field goal
but um in the end we were right there
but
denver's pass rush was too much for us
on that final play
you win some you lose some talk speaking
of that
you know i had a couple buddies come
over and uh during the second half
um the kids were asleep and everything
went out
smoked a stick and uh i was watching the
beginning of the green bay game and it
looked you know up 10 nothing i was
thinking like all right they're clicking
today
you know tom's yelling at the offensive
line again i don't know what's going to
happen and all of a sudden i'm out there
my buddy
texts me he goes brady's killing us
so it seemed to me that uh the
buccaneers defense
was what got them in a position to win
that game so i recorded that i got to
watch that one
and i'm kicking myself that i didn't
record the titans game
because uh that would seem to be a wild
one there was a lot of weird ones today
like [ __ ] atlanta kicking the [ __ ]
out of
whether it beat the vikings i think some
a lot of people you know if you bet any
favor today i think you got your [ __ ]
ass kicked
but um mike brabel
i was talking to my a friend of mine i
was going he's a [ __ ] good coach
guys you know beat us last year in the
playoffs
and he's got that team playing
tremendous let's look at some nfl scores
here shall we let's see what happened a
lot of
a lot of craziness um
titans came back to win that game 42-36
ravens hang on they were they were
handling the eagles the eagles fly
eagles fly they came back made it a game
falcons that was the game 40 to 23. who
the [ __ ] had that score
nobody the woeful jets 24 nothing
getting smoked down in philly
buccaneers 38 10. so the packers never
never scored again
wow um i know there was a pick six and
then they picked uh there was another
pick
that uh went down to like the three yard
line because brady didn't have like
gaudy stats
um 49 is handling the ram so far
and joe burrow gets back on track with
another 300-yard game
lsu
loving it um they came back and won
today right
no they lost [ __ ] the colts came back
holy [ __ ] crazy games today
giants got their first win over the team
from washington can they say the team
that used to have the racist name
washington washington the washington we
used to have a racist name
and now we're not gonna if we can't have
a racist name we're not calling
ourselves anything
no i'm sure that they're trying to
figure out i mean because now you're
going to be married to this next name
you know what i mean and i know they're
already thinking like well
the washington bullets sounded cool now
they're the wizards so i think that i
think washington redskins formerly the
redskins
are doing the smart thing by taking
their time
you know it's hard it's hard to come up
with a good name
this late in the game you know
all the all the ferocious animal names
are taken
a lot of the weather is gone right
you got thunder you got lightning what
are you gonna have like a
sun shower the washington sun showers
can't do that
bears lions tigers
all these names are taken right you
could be the football tigers there's no
tigers in dc right
there's no lions in detroit none of it
makes sense but you know what there's a
bunch of packers up there in green bay
uh chief's bills tomorrow here's mike
where is my question
here is my question because i know the
browns got the [ __ ] kicked out of them
today 38-7 so my question
considering that the uh buffalo bills
took their their first
loss last week my question is
were were were the cleveland did the
cleveland browns and the buffalo bills
get exposed
that maybe they weren't quite there
where everybody thought or
is it a typical football season are you
going to lose a game well the bill's got
the chiefs tomorrow so i'm going to be
watching that
um i did watch the bills game last week
where they lost and i finally got to
watch josh allen like a whole game that
guy's a [ __ ] man
dude he is gonna be a problem for the
patriots
for as long as that kid can play he
looks great and then also
i got i watched the whole game um
uh what was it that uh san diego
with uh herbert justin herbert man
they ended up losing the game i watched
the saints game
and i was very impressed and then as an
old man it was great to see drew brees
come back
and beat the young kids so um i don't
know a lot of a lot of [ __ ] crazy
crazy
i bet there's a lot of people had their
heads in their hands like i'm gonna lose
my shirt today
all of a sudden to win their bet and
then vice versa people taking a bunch of
[ __ ] money that they thought they
already won
and put it on the four o'clock game only
to see that disappear
how many times you've done that called
your bookie at halftime like dude this
game's a lock
bomb um
anyway so oh billy freckles
has been uh eating tremendously well
except for today today did not go well
because last night was date night with
my lovely wife
and uh we just ordered in and we ordered
a nice
[ __ ] rib eye steak right
little mashed potatoes some of that
spinach with the cream in it there
the cream of spinach right we did all of
that [ __ ]
and it was the classic postmates where
he's just like yeah we left it at the
door
and i opened my front door and it ain't
there and i'm looking in the bushes
i'm looking in these bushes i'm under
the car i'm [ __ ] looking for coyote
footprints
what the [ __ ] happened i can't be a
coyote unless the thing had thumbs and
was able to open the bag cause if
something ripped it apart i'd see the
bag right i've watched enough csi
i know there's going to be evidence
there's going to be some blood splatter
um so we e we text the guy back
or the lady back and we're like yeah
it's not here
and then postmates like well he
delivered it it's like well i'm sure he
[ __ ] did he didn't deliver where it's
supposed to go
uh turned out this kid had like
dyslexia so our neighbor up the street
ended up [ __ ] having the thing
so at that point i had already made
waffles which is my default meal
for dinner i'm just like [ __ ] it i'm
making waffles so i already made waffles
and um so we had this [ __ ] beautiful
ribeye steak
and um this morning uh we made like some
steak
breakfast tacos with that and i was
thinking don't eat this bill if you eat
this you're gonna eat bad for the rest
of the [ __ ] day and guess what
i ate it and that's exactly what i did
uh i ate
pretty healthy for lunch but then
tonight i was just like hey you want to
get a [ __ ]
you want to get a cheesesteak uh you
want to get a cheesesteak and then
that wasn't open i'm like i'd love a
fried chicken sandwich i'm telling you
if you eat bad it wasn't really bad but
it was
it was bad enough so today's my bad day
but then tomorrow
i'm gonna be on it again six days six
days on
i'm gonna eat well try to go for my old
man walks
still rehabbing the shoulder still
[ __ ] uh i'm
i'm i'm strengthening it now i'm past
the pain
and everything i'm up to the three pound
weights
i'm old i'm old i should just go to
germany and get my [ __ ] blood spun
should just do that one of the one of
those [ __ ] things
come back with like bionic shoulders um
porsche
level shoulders um whatever i'm doing it
how the [ __ ] i'm trying to do it so
uh oh and then also i i spent a little
bit of today
looking over my mail-in ballot um
and like most people i already know who
i'm voting for but it's the questions
you know trying to figure out what the
[ __ ]
a yes means and what a no means got this
commercial out here it's like if you
vote
if you vote no if you vote yes on blah
blah blah
question 23 or something i could die
all these old people and people with
kidney problems they're going to shut it
down i'm going to die
if you vote yes i'm going to die so i'm
like alright well [ __ ] that i'm voting
no
then you go online it's like actually
that's a misleading ad
and it's just like or are you misleading
that added
is that accurate or is the ad misleading
enormously
why do people have to [ __ ] lie
if this is why if this is if this is
really good for us
why do they always lie why is it [ __ ]
legal
to have a yes me no and a no mean yes
like i i
you know what it is maybe because people
are too [ __ ] stupid
there's just too many [ __ ] stupid
people out there and they have to they
gotta [ __ ]
i don't know i'm big on blaming the
general public now
all right i'm done with this blaming
politicians and all of this other [ __ ]
we're all part of it everybody's a
[ __ ] problem and i am a [ __ ] just
like everybody else so i am taking the
whole week
i'm going to read all the questions i'm
going to figure out what i want to do
and then i'm going to fill it out i'm
going to put it in the mailbox
and then one of the postman is going to
take all of those ballot
my wife and my ballot and he's going to
throw at the [ __ ] ocean
okay but i'll know that i did my part
and i'll get a little sticker and i'll
walk around with i voted on my t-shirt
i voted so there um
yeah i mean i guess there's this
like the library has like this yellow
box that's like the thing you're
supposed to stick the thing in and you
have the best chance that they don't
throw it out not like with the other
ones
they don't throw them out right there's
always that that's that famous story
right
of when uh john kennedy ran how the
chicago mob was throwing [ __ ]
votes out in the alley my whole time
growing up i always heard that story and
i always just pictured
these wise guys with their shiny suits
just throwing this bucket of paper
into the alley which and then as i got
older it was like
that's probably just like a figure of
speech that they threw at an alley they
probably actually
you know took it somewhere buried it or
[ __ ] burned it
you know put some cement on it and
dropped it in the ocean
you know how they do you know the three
ways they whack you right
i think i've watched enough sopranos see
you watch csi you know how to [ __ ]
look for evidence you watch the little
sopranos you get how the mob works
i mean i don't know why people read
books
why read a book when they could just
show you just you just watch a tv show
that's about it right and then you know
all about it
like i never need to go to philadelphia
again i watch always sunny in
philadelphia and it's like that's what
they do they get three four friends
together they buy a bar
and then they have adventures that's
what's going on in philly
right minneapolis she got married tyler
moore she spins around she throws her
hat up in the air
say it elmo's fire that's what chicago's
i'm sorry i ran out of ideas here
um oh man my daughter said the cutest
thing to me
and i knew she was like buttering me up
too she had this little
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was this
little toy or something like that and it
broke
and she comes up to me and she's just
like dad dad can you fix my toy can you
fix my toy it was this little wooden
like figurine and like the the arms were
made out of string that went through the
piece of wood and then it had two like
wooden
balls for hands on it um not a lot of
detail with this toy by the way
so somehow one of the balls came off and
the string came up
and she's like can you fix this so i try
to thread the needle to get it through
and it doesn't want to go through the
other side i was like i don't know what
i need some sort of tool
to pull this thing through i don't know
how i could get this thing through and
she just goes
she goes daddy you can fix this she goes
you fixed
you fixed my book cause i changed the
battery she has this book on
hip hop or something like that we got
over in france you just press the button
and it'll play like the you know
missy elliott song as you learn about
her and stuff
and all i did was change the battery so
now she just thinks i can fix everything
so she goes daddy you can fix it you fix
my
book you fix my bike you you can fix
anything
you know why because you're a great dad
she said that because you're a great dad
now she didn't say
because you're a great dad because she
thinks i'm a great dad is
well the last time she said you're a
great dad
was the first time she ever said it my
heart melted
and i was like oh and i gave her this
big hug i said thank you for saying that
that makes me feel so good right
so little kids they they they file that
away
so she the only reason why she said
there you're such a great dad
because you're a great dad is because
she wanted me to fix the thing
but i had to check with my wife i go
she's manipulating me right and she just
looked at me
the side eye and just nodded so
uh i gotta fix the thing now though
i think i just need i don't know how i'm
gonna get the hand on but if i take a
little phillips screwdriver
because i have the one for little kid
toys
you know what i mean because the little
kid toys have those phillips head
screwdrivers
that are like this like the size of a
screw on like your watch
so i had to go you got to buy like
jeweler tools to change the [ __ ]
battery on these things right
which by the way i've been doing really
good with about my cursing around my
kids been doing really well
i got it down where now all i say is
effin
well i'm honey i'm trying to fix the
effing thing but it's
and at this point my daughter's like
we'll just go da da don't say bad words
i'm like i said f and i'm like all right
you're right you're right
you're right it's not as bad but i'm
still in the pg-13
area so they've been kind of staying on
me
for that stuff but um anyway so the glow
of doing snl is uh
is still with me but i now i need to
replace the material that i used on the
show
and uh so last oh speaking of which i
watched uh
snl last night uh issa rae who
killed it and uh i gotta tell you if you
missed it last night try to find
um on the weekend update
heidi gardner did this thing about the
the chick from the 80s that does too
much coke
and it's literally the the character arc
of i
i was trying to remember like i'm like i
know i've seen this movie but she was
doing an amalgam of all of that
right from when the chick says hey
where's the after party
to starting to hit on the guy to being
coked out of her mind
to then realizing that her dreams aren't
going to come true it was [ __ ]
amazing
and uh both desk pieces i thought were
great um alex moffatt killed it as one
of the trump kids
i just him and mikey day the whole thing
was awesome so
i'd psyched i'm back into the show i
don't have any gigs so now i'm gonna
tape it every week
um i think um john mulaney hosts this
week
so uh anyway the hell am i talking about
yeah so i had to um
i had to uh you know i got to go do a
set right so
somebody called me up say man i got a
little time here it's like a barber shop
a parking lot behind a barber shop so
i'm like
out in santa monica so i'm like all
right i'll go i'll go do this [ __ ] and i
went up and i had like a new bit
that i can tell it has potential
it's got all the guts and everything on
there but it just it wasn't
quite uh where it needed to be but uh
i definitely got enough laughs that i
feel like i can kind of work that thing
out so i was very excited about that
and um it was fun to do just
show and now move forward after that
stratosphere thing just happened to get
back into the whole
you know slugging it out and all that i
just had such a great week i went down
in uh steve burns movie
um opening act he had a little uh
premiere for that you know socially
distanced premiere
went down got you know most of the cast
was there so i just you know
i brought my wife down turn it into like
a little date night
the whole thing was awesome but um i
will tell you though
uh definitely now with the two kids
i'm ready for bed at 8 30 at night but i
realized if i then jump in the shower
wake myself up and then get in the car
you know
and listen to some tunes i i can i can
get that second wind
i can get the second win but i swear to
god we were getting ready to go out to
go see
uh steve burns movie which is streaming
everywhere right now which got a great
review and variety
um we were both like going oh my god
i could go to bed right now could you go
to bed i could go to bed right now
[ __ ] hilarious well like what
happened to us it's like well we're
parents yeah and i'm also [ __ ] 52 i
should have been saying this years ago
if i
if i didn't idle so [ __ ] high you
know i've always wanted to be a chill
guy i don't know what happened
it's just not in the [ __ ] cards for
me
so um anyway
um that was kind of my uh
that was kind of my week i didn't watch
any of the debates or any of that type
of [ __ ] i just can't handle uh
i can't handle the choices
i just can't handle the [ __ ] choices
and i just i don't want to talk about it
i don't want to i who gives a [ __ ]
it's just you know gives a [ __ ] i i so
give a [ __ ] that i can't watch it
i can't watch it and i've just really
made a decision that what i'm gonna try
to do
is when i go around in my life is i'm
just gonna really try to be nice to
people
you know which sounds stupid but i just
that's the only way i can see to try and
combat
what the [ __ ] it is that i'm watching on
tv and i'm watching people
screaming and yelling at each other on
on on social media about
it's just like why don't i you know
i stop watching this and just go around
and just be nice to people
and polite and thank them just go out of
your way to do that
talk about the weather
just go back to like you know
a simpler time which is always dangerous
when a white guy says that let's go back
to a simpler time
um i mean just as far as like common
courtesy
amongst people like i'm trying to do
that it makes me feel
good to do [ __ ] like that and um
and i got a little down time now um i
know we are doing season
five of ephesus family i got a little
downtime so where me and my wife are
gonna try to get into a new show we're
gonna watch uh
uh this season's fargo with chris rock
so we're gonna watch start watching that
tonight excited about that
and with that let's do a little bit of
uh let's do a little bit of the ad
reads here um adam and eve
uh okay this is a sex toy everybody hey
hey hey keep it clean here keep it clean
adam and eve um
so this is all just uh is this all uh
heterosexual stuff
because it's adam and eve what about
adam you know the old joke adam and
steve
adam and they adam who used to be eve
and now eve is adam
huh come on adam and eve can we be a
little more progressive with your dildos
all right monday morning podcast is
brought to you by adam and eve
adam and eve says the best part of
staying at home is playing at home oh
jesus
sex toys make being at home way
more enjoyable hell even shopping from
home is more enjoyable
when you're shopping for sex toys adam
and eve has
thousands of products is that besos
besos guys from [ __ ] amazon gonna try
to get in on this
god forbid somebody orders something
from someplace else
[ __ ] send you your dildo with your
name [ __ ]
uh carved on the side or whatever
engraved on the side in a
[ __ ] refrigerator box why does that
guy put [ __ ] in such big boxes
it's unbelievable he wants to enslave
the world and destroy the planet that's
my guess all right let's get back to the
dildos here sex toys
um and adam and eve has thousands of
thousands of
products so there's something for
thousands of products hang on a second
i think i'm going to adamandeve.com here
thousands of products let's see
here we go this is going to be on my
search engine adam
ah why am i doing this adam and eve i
want to see what the [ __ ] they got going
on over there
oh this is just going to be uh
official sites for adult toys i would
have thought about a bunch of religious
[ __ ] all right here we go
oh up to 85 off vibrators who says
there's no deals during a pandemic
come on load up here
america's favorite adult store 100
discrete packaging
well thank you for not shrink wrapping
that
fake fist
i really need to be more mature in this
[ __ ] ad read
it's slowly loading everybody all right
um
god knows my now my laptop's gonna crap
out and then [ __ ] the nerd working on
it's gonna see that i went to adam and
eve
all right uh anatomy has i'm waiting for
it to load has thousands of products
so there's something for everyone free
stuff is awesome but free stuff
to spice up your bedroom is even better
take advantage of the downtime and
choose almost
any one item at 50 off
when you do you'll also get 10 free
boredom busting gifts including
six spicy movies uh
a three-piece bonus kit
jesus well okay we got the we got the
[ __ ] we got the fake fest we got a
[ __ ]
a movie uh what else you got a a
zip up hood um it's like gordon chicken
here
what do you want you want a couple of
thighs and a [ __ ] dildo
all right three-piece bonus kit and best
of all
free shipping delivered discreetly right
to your door just remember to use the
code burr
b-u-r-r i don't want my name on this
[ __ ] at checkout go to adamandeve.com
and use the
uh and use that offer code burr
b-u-r-b-u-r-r
one more time that's adam and eve
code b-u-r-r the [ __ ] thing's not
loading of course because i played nine
million dollars for the [ __ ] internet
the site's not loading all right oh look
who's back everybody
it's all zip
zip recruiters here oh wait let's go
back to adam and eve
enter email address go [ __ ] yourself
all right submit all right
here's my fake email
and we go aol.com
so you know it's not real submit
can i go on your site
submit it's a weird word to use on a sex
site huh
oh yeah dude this this this is like yeah
this is
what you would think it would be all
right we'll get back to that it's it's
loading it's loading everything
that code is everybody i do i'm gonna do
the new intro here because i don't think
zip recruiter wants that [ __ ]
flavor with their reed oh look who it is
everybody it's
all zip
you know businesses have tried to be
flexible this year
from working remotely to pivoting their
business models
for long-term survival and growth share
some of your own examples are following
well
i used to do my podcast all by myself
before the pandemic
and now i continue to do it all by
myself well i still have guests everyone
if i have a guest they're
sitting across the [ __ ] room all
right share some of your that was my
example
restaurants are moving their dining
outdoors and adding takeout and catering
some customers
oh sorry some consumer packaged products
companies have shifted to focus more on
surface cleaners
or personal hygiene products major
retailers are now
selling face face masks
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business these pivots
have made your job even more challenging
especially if you have to hire for
a brand new role uh thankfully there's
one place you can always count on
to make hiring faster and easier ole zip
dot com slash burr well when you post a
job on zip recruiter it's
it gets sent to over 100 of the top job
boards with one click zip
powerful technology finds people with
the right skills and experience for your
job and
actively invites them to apply it's no
wonder four out of five
employees who post on zip
okay uh get a quality candidate within
the first day see for yourself right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruiter.com spell it out uh
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot-com b-u-r-r let zip
take hiring off your plate so you can
focus on growing your business
all right oh look who it is butcher box
everybody
your friend during a pandemic when there
was lines like we were in
[ __ ] russia back in the day uh at the
grocery store look at this [ __ ] butcher
box
when it comes to meat quality matters uh
but there's more to it than texture and
taste
nothing is more important than eating
quality food it can be hard to navigate
complicated labels at the grocery store
trying to figure out if they're truly
organic
because they can say that they are when
they're not because all politicians take
that blood money
uh but luckily today's sponsor butcher
box believes everyone deserves high
quality
humanely sourced meat never be with the
sierra joe biden or donald trump talk
about that
i think butcher box is uh is is right
out in front where they need to be
never be without something to cook for
dinner because there's always meat in
the freezer
uh my favorite cut of meat is their uh
heritage breed pork
i love that pork chop uh every month
butcher box ships and
a curated selection of high quality meat
right to my home
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones their their hamburger
meat's delicious too
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
enough for 24 individual meals
unless you're eating like an animal like
me today maybe it cuts in half
options like 100 grass-fed and finished
beef free-range organic chicken my
favorite the heritage breed pork
wild-caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what you're gonna do
and sugar nitrate free bacon
packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way
uh you can customize your box or go with
one of theirs either way you're gonna
get exactly what you want it's the
it's the way meat should be butcher box
is the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy humanely raised
meat uh with butcher bucks you get the
high quality meat
uh the highest quality meat around for
just six bucks a meal
and they even have free shipping
nationwide except alaska in hawaii
i mean alaska you can shoot your own
[ __ ] meat in hawaii you know
what are they supposed to do you you're
out there middle of the ocean right now
butcher box is offering new members two
lobster tails
and two filet mignons for free mignol
for free in their first box that's two
lobster tails and two filet mignons
for free in your first box just go to
butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com sorry
um by the way whenever they serve a
lobster tail i always think what what'd
they do with the rest of the lobster
you know they make a lobster roll out of
that they they use it for other things
they throw it out
i mean the [ __ ] thing's dead you're
boiled in alive can you at least eat the
whole thing
am i crazy am i thinking too much about
a crustacean
um i love when they do that [ __ ] they
think like they know what they're
thinking oh the
the lobster can't they can't feel it it
doesn't know what's happening it's like
oh you also can't express
in a human way what it's feeling
people say that about dogs i saw this
[ __ ] cute little dog video
today going this this one golden
retriever is looking at another golden
retriever and could tell the thing was
having a bad dream
so it's so it was laying down next to it
it just sort of licked its nose
it's like aren't you sort of projecting
you don't know what the [ __ ] the dogs
think you don't even what is the dog
dreaming about
you know it's over there grinding its
teeth it needs a night guard do you
abuse the dog
the [ __ ] is a dog worrying about
it's [ __ ] stupid ah people all right
my bookie hey my bookie how the [ __ ] you
doing
uh between the nfl college ball and the
major league baseball playoffs there's
no
shortage of sports to watch or to put
your money on
and with the way the last presidential
debate went it won't be long before my
bookie has odds on donald trump to join
the wwe
uh whether you tuned in or not i hope
you guys cashed in on some of those
debate
uh prop bets that went up because we
were several because there were several
that could have been considered free
money
trump to mention russia that was a lock
can you really bet on this [ __ ] what a
great
way to make a presidential debate
watchable during these
these new normal times um and that
that's the best part about betting at my
bookie they offer great value in their
odds and lines whether you're betting on
the nfl action
or their crazy prop bets there's always
a little something for everyone and
always
always cash to be one uh if you've been
uh
i've been playing in the my bookie i
don't want to talk about i've been
getting my [ __ ] ass
especially after today i've been getting
my ass kicked
into my bookie super contest this season
i hope you guys are winning
because it's only ten dollars to entry
to enter uh for the chance to win a
share of a hundred grand
ten bucks to win a hundred grand i mean
you're increasing yeah yeah your money
by
uh ten thousand oh my god did i do that
right by ten thousand percent
uh in in cash prizes for a ten dollar
investment
i don't think you can beat that ten
bucks turn that into a hundred grand
sign me up twice
right can i do that probably not another
good investment to make would be to fade
the atlanta falcons for the rest of the
year if they blow another lead late well
that didn't happen today did it
uh whatever you do if you're going to
bet this season bet my bookie i don't
[ __ ] you doing
and use my promo code burr b-u-r-r to
grab yourself
a deposit match um when you join because
who doesn't like free money on top of
their deposit that's promo code burr
b-u-r-r
to claim your bonus at mybookie.com
let's get to some of the questions um
overseas point of view
um dear billy do americans know how
crazy they
are when it comes to believing their own
government's propaganda
yeah well maybe someday we can be like
you and not believe your
government's propaganda go [ __ ] yourself
i know we're i know we're
we're in a crazy time over here
everybody realizes that
all right and what you're doing is
you're going on and you're watching
videos of the dumbest
mouth-breathing [ __ ] americans and
you think they're all like that
they're not okay we know we're living in
a fish bowl over here what country are
you from
all right you speak about your news
stations that have members of your own
governments intelligence agencies
telling people things with no facts or
documents almost
every day my country has experienced a
cia back coup
in the last 20 years oh sorry about that
uh
maybe i shouldn't have gone in this
harbin this person this isn't anything
new to your country's foreign policy
uh no it isn't it's humorous watching
the u.s trick their own people with the
same tactics they use to create
militant uprisings okay touche
these strategies are as old as time and
a poor understanding of history is the
blame
uh uh no it isn't it isn't it's the fact
that everybody is watching tv
and that's what's being spewed at them
and if in your country if they were
doing that to you which i'm sure they
are
you guys are in a bubble the problem
with now is
you should have dipped in saying you
from another country that got oppressed
by us
and you you should try to be building
bridges with us
so we can then stop yelling and being
afraid and then look at our leaders and
question what the [ __ ] they're doing
all you did with your beginning was put
me on the defensive
to defend my country all right
oh god all right sorry here we go um
so it's you enjoy watching our country
go down this [ __ ] so what am i
supposed to feel bad about yours
i still do all right these strategies
are as old as guys the er
the international community deemed your
russia story
is false this is probably a russian bot
here as well as the u.s domestic courts
if you don't believe me please read any
international journalist
who has no ties to any intelligent
agency well if you can
find me that person i will read it uh
despite this your
news focuses on things instead of your
military sprawl
yeah dude everybody knows this everybody
knows this
what are we gonna do they have the guns
we don't i mean we're all
i don't know what to tell you um it's a
big country buddy
we're trying over here okay you never
prosecute any of your politicians
and it is very clear that this will make
economy expert what
uh wait it will make it easier for uh
for your you to continue to be weakened
from the inside
absolutely i agree i am not an economy
expert but here in my country one of the
quickest way our
our system was destabilized was
the excessive spending oh dude i mean
you're 20 years late on this one
do you think americans are just ignorant
or do you think
they're just too dumb to know they're
being lied to
um well i mean you just kind of
no i don't i think i think every country
the leader is lying to you and painting
a rosier picture
and saying that what they're doing is
great and what the other people want to
do is bad
um i don't think politics
is unique in our country
i think this is what they do everywhere
and i think
if you're have the military sprawl that
we do and you
[ __ ] with so many other countries people
hate
you and they focus on you and uh you
know i i'm not gonna start naming other
countries but other countries you know
aren't exactly this is a weird time dude
so yeah i know we're completely [ __ ]
up uh you kind of trashed us you
offered no solutions um
here's the deal the people in this
country are just like the people in your
country okay everybody wants to walk
around
feel safe get a sandwich find love have
a couple of kids maybe
and just be okay and know that their
kids are gonna be okay that's what
everybody wants
okay so we're no different than from
wherever you're from
all right and as far as all of that
other stuff
i mean just
how life has changed
so fast and i'm not talking about the
pandemic with technology
in 24-hour news networks and all of this
type of [ __ ] and then
deregulating rules of ownership of media
where all of a sudden that you are
basically only getting
the viewpoint of a very small amount of
people
it's really easy to manipulate
people and you know not for nothing
you know every time there's a war both
sides dehumanize the other people
they say still all that [ __ ] that the
terrorists talk about there were
infidels and all of the
whatever the [ __ ] that means it's like
i'm not infidel i'm a [ __ ] jerk off
this is just where i was born
trying to get through the [ __ ] week
and pay my bills like everybody else and
they just build up all of this [ __ ]
i remember back in world war ii there's
footage of
um japanese women
throwing their kids off a cliff and
jumping off a cliff too when they saw
the american troops
because their propaganda said that we
would eat them
if they were caught um
you know and we said all kinds of
[ __ ] crazy racist [ __ ] about people
all
that we're gonna go bomb and blow up
because if they didn't
i guess people be like why are you
dropping
explosives on fellow human beings
like i'll be honest with you i cannot
believe in 2020 that
war is still legal
you know i get having a gun to defend
yourself
in your house especially if you live in
the middle of nowhere
you know by the time the cops get there
whatever was gonna happen was gonna
happen so i understand
people that want to do that but this
whole [ __ ] thing of like hey we think
this and you think that you don't think
what we think
or you won't let us come in there and
take advantage of you so now we're going
to just
kill more your people than you can kill
of ours so then you'll bow down to us
is um i don't know
it's so funny this whole progressive
time that we're supposed to be in
nobody's [ __ ] with war
it's nuts and as far as all of that [ __ ]
about the economic thing like
you know the second we went over to the
middle east and had no exit plan
no exit strategy he's got weapons of
mass destruction oh i guess he didn't
i mean so now what said we just stay
well we destabilized it now we can't
leave you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't know i blame bankers in the
other companies for all of this [ __ ]
that's what i do and i've said it
forever you just give the
give the oil company the sun just say
that's yours
and we'll all switch to [ __ ] solar
power even if at the end of the day
throwing out the
old soul of [ __ ] is not as good is
is is not as even if it isn't as clean
as oil and coal and all that [ __ ] at
least
we can just leave people in the middle
east alone
and let them solve their own [ __ ]
problems and just get out of there
save a bunch of [ __ ] money i don't
know why they don't just do that
um they're all [ __ ] focusing on the
goop there
all right workplace issues workplace
issues
um hey there bald boston billy ball
saga uh recently i've been promoted to
work
to shop manager congratulations in the
pa in the past i managed a team of 20
of a 20 year old warehouse workers and
rocked it i'm 35
they looked up to me and as an adult a
man of great knowledge life experience
and wealth
with the promotion well jesus
uh that sounds great with the promotion
my direct reports are now
a bunch of bald ball saggers like
yourself
well into their well into their 50s um
great at what they do and great guys but
i can feel the tension
already from them uh when i am giving
them a task
like how do you think i should approach
gaining their respect
as a boss oh so now you're 35
and you're you're managing these
curmudgeons
um
gain their respect as a boss don't take
any [ __ ] from them
is what i would do don't be an [ __ ]
and don't get drawn into any sort of
name calling
or [ __ ] biggest dick contest or any
of that [ __ ] that ego crap
just you just got to keep your cool and
i'll read the rest i have thought about
sucker punching one of them
at the water cooler though effective
likely not the best career move okay so
i'm sensing
they're not respecting you i thought
about constant praise and positive
affirmation i.e treating them like a
child
who has done good i have also thought
about sitting
them around one by one and asking what
change they want to see
i'm only three days into this job and
tried none of the above yet
um in all seriousness i really care
about my job love my work love this
company just want to do well in this new
role
seeing as you are around their age and
as abrasive as they are
how would you want a young handsome punk
like myself
to lead you okay first of all dude
you're not young you're 35.
i guess what we would consider you young
i mean i would consider you young maybe
you're saying it that way um
well i'm not a good example of a 50 year
old
uh i'm self-employed and really don't
have a real job i mean i
act like a jerk off and get paid for it
i mean so
i'm in a good mood a lot of the time um
i would guess that one of them wanted
the position that you got and you got it
instead
so they're probably acting like a bunch
of real housewives and maybe talking
[ __ ] about you
what i think you need to do is you need
to lead
by example okay don't let them get under
your skin
let them say i mean you have you are
their boss they have to listen to you
so what you have to do is you got to
handle yourself like a man
because they're probably already
thinking all right this guy's a [ __ ]
millennial he's going to be overly
sensitive he's going to be that
this is what i would do i would you know
i keep them in check they want to they
want to cross a couple of lines or
whatever
just show that you can f you're you're a
[ __ ] guy that can you know take their
[ __ ] or whatever but like there's no
reason for you to [ __ ] adjust to them
you know what i mean uh what i would do
is i would i would
tow the company line and handle yourself
respectfully
and handle them respectfully anything
beyond that
they can go [ __ ] themselves and
um once they see that you're not budging
because they're just testing you to see
if you're gonna be like the substitute
teacher that they can [ __ ] around with
um yeah you don't have to name call and
just be like you know i'll send your
[ __ ] ass upstairs fast you make your
[ __ ] tie tack spin you don't need to
do any of that [ __ ]
just don't take any of their [ __ ] don't
flinch
and uh you know i would i and i would
never belittle any of them in front of
the other ones at that point you got to
come in the office
and then just be like all right off the
record what the [ __ ] is your problem
you know i maybe can't talk like that in
the office anymore that's how they used
to do it
anyway good luck with that though all
right there young and handsome
35 year old all right my mother is gonna
kill
my family with junk food oh boy hey
billy burrito sorry about the click bait
tag line but i'm really hoping you can
give me some advice here
i'm 24 year old guy who's 5'7 and
pounds oh that's not good i live with my
parents
still not by choice just don't have the
funds to move well it's the middle of a
pandemic it's a tough year man
and i've been trying to change my diet
for over a year now i started march 19th
march 2019 i was 300 pounds and dropped
to 220
by september through a fad diet things
were going good but the holidays came
around
and with it came some calories i moved
past it only gaining a few pounds and
resolving to lose them by cleaning up my
diet even more good for you
but around then for some reason my
mother kicked up the amount of junk food
she kept around the house by a
by a lot uh by a lot she didn't stop
went from having a few snacks around the
house to having over 60
of the groceries being garbage sugar
food
with all that crap laying around the
kitchen and my face and and less than
normal food
it got hard to remain resolute
okay so he says why not just buy your
own food you may ask
i absolutely try to the problem is the
way that we've worked
out my rent situation i simply pay for
two large
family expenses in exchange for living
there that being our phone
bill and our groceries to make things
simple i just give
her my bank card and tell her the
groceries i'd like and she gets
uh and she gets that and then gets the
family groceries
it makes it all more frustrating that
all this
junk is being purchased with my money
uh so obvious so the obvious solution is
just to go and buy the groceries myself
right wrong
she winds up making separate runs just
for snacks
sugary cereals donuts cake cookies chips
soda etc
we're constantly overstocked on the
stuff whenever i leave my room i see
you're eating at least one of them
which brings me to the part i'm really
worried about yeah
she you're you're living with an addict
basically a food addict she's
got it's happening today i had those
steak and egg burritos
and i ate like now i'm on the [ __ ]
crack again so
you got to get off it um and then you
won't crave it then you won't buy it
all right anyways plowing ahead um all
of this crap is making my family super
unhealthy
my seven and eight-year-old brother and
sister have both steadily
been steadily gaining weight i will try
to control them when i'm home
asking them how many cookies they had or
making them eat some real food for lunch
instead of
a third huge bowl of cereal they just go
around me and ask my mom if they can eat
more sugar
who seems to have completely stopped
giving a [ __ ] about their health
ah dude this is getting is there a light
at the end of this [ __ ] sugar tunnel
here
um yesterday i literally watched her
give up
give up on trying to get my little
brother to eat a sandwich and hand
him an ice cream bar for dinner
every time i try and push them to eat
healthy they react to me like i'm a mean
brother for doing so
and i'm starting to resent my mother
from making me feel like a bad guy for
wanting my siblings to be healthy
and that's not even mentioning how large
my mother is getting
yeah dude you need a family meeting here
i think she has to be approaching 300
pounds
she gets completely winded just walking
down our driveway to the mailbox
and i hear her struggling just to make
it up and down the stairs every day
i'm incredibly concerned about her
well-being and have even voiced this to
her before
she will say something like yeah i know
it's a problem and she'll even discuss
diets she heard about but then never do
anything i've asked her to get
a gym membership with me and she talks
about it like it's some kind of fantasy
like
oh yeah we should do that i read about
an exercise program
or so and so told me about one gym i was
really thinking about checking out
but it's all non-committal [ __ ] she
says in the moment
and never follows up on sorry for the
long email
i hope you read it i could really use
the advice love your snl appearance
thank you you absolutely killed it
and i'm looking forward to the next time
you're at hilarity's in cleveland thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah you got to sit down and have a uh a
heart-to-heart and just say
just say mom i'm worried you're gonna
die
well we can't do this we need to do we
have to do better i'm not saying get rid
of all the ice cream and chips
we just have to tone it down and then
maybe just go out and join a gym
and get her a membership too and just go
like just walk on the treadmill with me
just do something to get her going but
that's a um
that's a tough thing you know and this
has been a really stressful year and i
think there's
like uh i was talking to a buddy of mine
and basically everybody in this pandemic
has gone one way or the other
they either got into really good shape
or they just
gained like 20 30 pounds so
um yeah man that's really hard
and it's literally like if you're living
with somebody who doesn't want to get
sober like somebody who doesn't want to
[ __ ]
buy good food uh first things first is
you gotta look out for yourself
and you gotta you gotta just stop eating
that [ __ ] that's laying around because
you don't want it
you don't wanna eat it you don't want
the result of it and you have to
mentally get past
the craving you know
and think about what you're doing to
your body and also know that all you
have to do is just sit down and eat a
garden salad
and it just levels it i feel like it
brings that sugar salt [ __ ]
bouncing back and forth it levels you
out and it makes you your brain
sane again as far as the next thing it
says that it wants to eat
and um
yeah but that's hard with the young kids
there too yeah i would sit down and talk
to her about it and just i would just
say listen i'm not eating this stuff
anymore
all right i'm not eating it anymore and
you know you're fat the kids are getting
fat my siblings are getting fat or
whatever
you kind of gotta in a nice way
you know it's it's usually your dad it'd
be easy
like dad you're getting tits what are we
doing here you know women you gotta you
gotta make sure
you gotta do the mini series you got to
make it nice little opening music
i don't know how but i i would go that
route uh good luck with that but uh
don't you know you work so hard to lose
that weight man don't get drawn into
somebody else's [ __ ]
food heroin binge here um all right well
good luck with that okay
marrying my step sister
all right dearest billy [ __ ] tits hey
uh my girlfriend and i have been
together for close to five years we have
what some would call a perfect
a picture-perfect relationship she's
cool as [ __ ]
smart funny and the most gorgeous woman
i've ever known
that's great uh we rarely argue and have
an incredible sex life oh what's gonna
happen here why would you write in if it
was so perfect
and it's been the equivalent of dating
my best friend oh wait a second i forgot
the title of this i bought a ring this
summer
and i'm preparing to pop the question
and spend the rest of my life with her
all that [ __ ] just got turned on its
[ __ ] head
we hosted thanksgiving for our families
at our house in 2019.
i lost my dad when i was a teenager and
she lost her mom
when she was a child our parents had
never met each other before this
thanksgiving dinner
the holiday went really well everyone
got along and i thought that was the end
of it oh no
fast forward to last week our parents
called us up and wanted to take us out
for dinner
oh no we met them at the restaurant and
they revealed that
unbeknownst to us they'd been seeing
each other without our knowledge since
thanksgiving dinner
and presented us with rings and a
marriage
license they took a trip to vegas
the week before and our parents got
[ __ ] married
all in capital letters i am now legally
in a relationship with my stepsister
i could have killed both of our parents
right then and there
at the table in my local
i'm not going to say the name of the
place the audacity
what the [ __ ] do i do i'm now
effectively dating my living stepsister
my feelings for her haven't changed but
how can i marry my stepsister
i think come on dude you were already
banging her before they got together
right
should i break up with the woman of my
dreams because my mom turned out to be a
huge [ __ ] and my
and her dad had zero problems banging
his daughter's boyfriend
mom all right dude you're in a very high
emotional state here
i need some advice on what to do from a
fellow freckled [ __ ]
to help guide me through this jerry
spring s situation
i have found myself smack in the middle
of huge fan snl mogul was the tits
monologue was the tits and as always go
[ __ ] yourself yeah [ __ ] that
for all you know they're gonna get
divorced marry who you're supposed to
marry
they did steal your thunder i mean now i
guess you got you got to elope you can't
have your and uh
who's presenting the rings my mom and
her dad also my stepdad
and her stepmom
crazy you need like disclaimers i stay
with her man
stay with it wow wow
they really [ __ ] it's like they came
in and stole your idea though i can see
how you're so upset
that is [ __ ] weird
and like selfish that they just went
ahead and did that
like do they think your relationship
with that woman is a joke
i really understand why you're upset i
wasn't thinking for a second i was just
thinking of
the logistics how it's embarrassing but
like this is
there's a ridiculous selfishness to this
but sometimes in love you have to be
selfish
i don't know dude
i don't know well at least uh
oh where's the silver lining in this at
least uh you'll have one less in-law
one of your in-laws you'll be related to
i don't know
i think you just rebooted the brady
bunches what you did greg marries marcia
um oh my nose
facial sorry all right employee
questions
apple store all right this is what i
asked people who work with the public i
wanted the top five dumb
questions that people have been asking
you and these
these have been great so far okay here
we go all right hey mr burr straight to
the point i worked at an apple store
from 2011 to 2018. you did your time
signed up for a second hitch didn't you
um since i know you love going there
here is the flip side i should got to
stop blaming that store for my own
ignorance on technology here is the flip
side
of what we as employees have to suffer
through with some of these mouth
breathers these these are all going to
be me
i've probably done all these top five
dumb questions at the apple store
i feel like paul schaefer should be
playing a little music right now all
right number five
question which nike shoes do you sell
here
answer we don't sell shoes here there's
an accessory that would go
into your shoe as part of the nike run
club
but people legit thought we sold nikes
for a time
i didn't know that is it nike or nike i
never knew
all right number four question do i get
a discount if i buy
multiple iphones max ipads
answer no but i can sell you multiple
devices
at full price yeah you got to be a
business i think to do that even then
you probably couldn't do it number three
why won't my phone ring hands me the
phone i flip the mute switch
to off on the side or turn off
do not disturb and hand it back
number two i've seen a lot of me in
these number two question
what's my apple wi-fi twitter facegram
instagram
email etc etc password answer
why would i a stranger know that i
haven't even been dumb enough to ask
that number one
drumroll anton figg uh where are the
microsoft
surfaces answer at the micro
microsoft store i like that you [ __ ]
give these people
[ __ ] i like it you can't get mad that
says genius on your shirt
you know you know i was going to get
upset but you know i don't mind taking
[ __ ] from a genius
uh thanks for all the laughs and
everything you do and we'll and continue
to do thank you best to you the lovely
neil and your two little ones
thank you very much well i think i've
asked dumber questions than that
with some more colorful verbiage
you know like why do i have to buy a
brand new [ __ ] everything
every single time one of your [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] cunty-ass
[ __ ] device that i don't even need
the last one was fine
do i need to buy a new [ __ ] whole new
charger system
from right into the wall of my house to
out in my [ __ ] car it's so goddamn
annoying
and why do you i want to talk about
apple and they [ __ ]
they just pay that [ __ ] fine
for damaging the environment every year
because it's cheaper
than actually [ __ ] trying to make
their [ __ ] a little more greener i don't
know what
where what world these people think
we're gonna live in at the end of this i
have no [ __ ] idea all right whatever
whatever
i pick on apple too much they're not the
only ones they're not the only ones
all right so we're back to adam and eve
all right shop now
shop now okay vibrators her favorites
they got rabbits clitoral they got wands
most wanted they got realistic a little
ball bag on that one vibrating
huge for size queens then they got for
guys
they got the fleshlight realistic
pocket [ __ ] for someone you know you
don't got a lot of time
uh best for backdoor
all right we'll stay out of that one oh
they got little whips and
[ __ ] fur fuzzy
what are the what do you call those
things the handcuffs
blindfold some lingerie
they got all that [ __ ] oh there you go
ebony adam and eve who
knew who knew um anyway
check out don't forget dean del rey has
ac dc's brian
johnson and angus young um on to promote
their new album power up which you can
pre-order on itunes now
on his let there be talk podcast please
check it out if you just want to
see two of the biggest rock legends of
the last 40 years
and then watch dean del rey arguably the
biggest fan of rock music
this country has ever produced watch him
cheesing
ear to ear totally geeking out that he
has
these guys on his podcast it's
incredible and i'm going to be
definitely checking that out
um all right that is it thank you for
listening to the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in on you
on thursday
you